it's actually pretty easy to beat 99% of
people because most people do the wrong
stuff and for me personally I have a
portfol of companies at acquisition.
comom that does over $250 million per
year and I make these videos because I
am really just shouting at my younger
self of all the mistakes that I was
making by working a lot on things that
didn't move my business the vast
majority of growth isms for the most
part are wrong because if they were
right people would do them and then grow
but most of growth is counter intuitive
so I want you to imagine your business
as a tree okay so let's say you've got
this tree and it's planted in the ground
and you're like where's the top of the
tree don't worry we'll get there and the
height of the tree over time let's just
imagine is your Revenue okay so as the
tree gets taller your Revenue goes up
okay now the problem is let's say that
you have these little offshoots right
that's these little these little these
little these little growth hey the these
are B+ problems hey we should add this
thing to our email sequence hey we
should do this thing for our fall what
happens is the resources from the tree
from you from the ground that are going
into this thing are getting shot out to
the side and so you are growing you feel
like you're solving problems but you're
still here at the same Revenue as you
were last year but once you cut these
things off then all of the resources go
right into the trunk and they just keep
growing and then your business continues
to stay focused on the one thing that is
going to move the tree up the most so
it's not about the amount of tasks that
you finish it's the amount of growth
each task gets you and this is why even
biblically they talk about the way to
keep a tree healthy is to prune it and
pruning literally means you're cutting
things off commitment is the elimination
of Alternatives which means commitment
is literally the recipe for growth is
that you focus all resources on on the
one growth path that you get the most
for right now you have a big list of
things that you think you should do and
what often happens is that you will do
number five number three maybe number
two because those are the ones that
you're like oh I can knock that out
pretty quick oh I can knock that out
pretty quick but what ends up happening
is you get to the end of the day and you
still have that number one thing that's
sitting there on your list and that
number one thing you probably know is
the most important thing that if you
only did that one thing it would make
the rest of the things on that list
irrelevant by comparison
but what ends up happening is that we do
the B+ problems all day because it makes
us feel good because we know how to
solve them the A+ problem is usually one
that's a little bit hairier it has more
variables it's more complex we have to
get into systems we have to do more
analysis and then we have to iterate to
figure out how to solve it and so
because of that we prefer the fast the
fast dopamine or whatever you want to
call it of solving the quick problem
rather than solving the most important
problem so fundamentally most people
want to do a good job I have found this
from the people who work at my companies
is that they want to do a good job and
so what they're afraid of is that if
they have this problem that's underneath
of their purview that you are going to
yell at them and say oh my
God ah look at these fires right but the
thing is is that if you just say dude
there's this massive fire right here
that's burning and by far will burn
everything to a crisp far more than
these itty B fires will that means that
it's okay that these burn and so when I
do a prioritization meeting especially
if it's a big turnaround thing or we got
to turn an apartment around something
like that like this is the most
important thing in the business I set
the agenda up front and I say hey as of
this point nothing that has happened
before today anyone is accountable for I
will blame no one for anything and so if
I ask you in the future of this
conversation who made this or what made
this happen I am not asking to blame you
I'm asking so that I can understand the
problem better so that we can solve it
together and by saying it's like as of
this moment there's Amnesia from the
past no one here will be responsible and
so by doing that the pressure in the
room they're like okay we're on the same
team and going forward if you get and
like I think you have to be specific
with this it's like John if you get
complaints from CS about this stuff your
turnarounds being slow that's okay you
can tell them I said it's fine hey Sarah
in legal if you're having this issue and
people are like hey we got to get these
contracts signed tell them I said it's
fine and remember I pay everybody's
paychecks and so at the end of the day
I'm the one who's got to sign it and I'm
telling you it's okay as hard as it is
for you because you guys all want to do
a good job to let these fires burn we
have to flex we have to focus on this
one otherwise this one's going to burn
us to a crisp I was on a call with one
of my portfolio teams and it was a paid
ads team and they were having issues
with pixel tracking and this issue had
been going on for three weeks and it was
because everyone was distracted everyone
was looking at all these different
funnels and pages and followup sequences
and fundamentally if the pixel is not
bringing in the right traffic none of
the conversion re optimization ever will
matter ever again if the pixel gets
worse and worse and worse because we're
seasoning it with worse data and if
you're like what the hell is Alex
talking about it don't worry it's just
payad stuff but fundamentally if you're
on a payad steam and you know what I'm
talking about if that is wrong Nothing
Else Matters and so the the difficulty
and this is what's tough is that you
have to look at all the other problems
and be like oh yeah all this stuff sucks
we're going to ignore that because if we
don't fix this none of that matters and
even as I was going up and pulling up
some of the pages I was like God this is
ugly and I told her I was like this is
so ugly we should fix this but we're not
going to today because today we're going
to fix this problem we're going to fix
the pixel that's it and once we fix the
pixel in all of these seven funnels once
it's fixed then we can go on to the next
thing but the next thing because if you
reassess you might find out that once
you fix the pixel issue some of your
conversion rate issues might go away
because maybe you're getting the right
traffic in there which is why you have
to always reassess after doing the
solution rather than trying to force Fe
like I think these are the top 10 would
you put eight above seven who cares
you're not even going to work on it
you're just going to work on the one and
then get that done and then you will see
with this new reality in this new
context which of these now will move the
needle the most and so Frank slutman who
as a three-time IPO uh entrepreneur
talks about this in his management book
where he basically focuses every company
on only one thing and so he says some
companies have five objectives some
companies have three objectives his
companies are only allowed to have one
because once you do that one thing and
this is something that I have found from
my experience is that let's say you had
that list of five things to do you have
those five quote priorities if you do
the one that matters the most what you
will often find is that number two
through five sometimes one become
irrelevant other times something over
here actually all of a sudden becomes
the next most important thing which
means that if you had done number three
number five number two on your list and
then done number one then you
figuratively would have wasted all of
the time doing 2 three and five Because
by the time you did number one it
actually made those Solutions IR
relevant everything that I'm talking
about right now is based on a concept
that we call the theory of constraints
which is that you have one thing in your
business that that is limiting your
growth it is the constraint of your
growth and once you
deconstruyendo
million a year so it's a decent sized
room um 25% over 5 million 50% over 1
million and so it's for legit business
owners we talk about this type of stuff
that really moves the needle for
businesses in a big way fundamentally
the goal of strategy which is the big
fancy word that people use is to
prioritize limited resources against
unlimited opportunities there are
unlimited things that you could do to
grow your business you could run Tik Tok
ads you could run LinkedIn ads you could
run LinkedIn outbound you could optimize
your site you could improve your sales
conversions there's a million things
that you could do to grow your business
but there is one thing that can grow
your business more than the others and
that one thing would pale or make
everything else pale in comparison and
so when people are considered excellent
strategists translate that into their
excellent at prioritizing but the real
best strategists see all of the moves
and probably some moves you don't see
that maybe the number one thing on your
list gets you a 2X but there's another
move that has a number one that's a 10x
and and so fundamentally you have to
prioritize against all things you could
do known and unknown and the people who
move the fastest in terms of distance
covered are the ones who get the most
for every unit of effort which is not
about how fast they do things but at how
much speed they cover with the things
they choose to do and so let me give you
a different analogy that you can think
of with so a lot of people have a little
wheel on their car and they're thinking
how do I make this thing spin faster
right they've got this little wheel and
they're like I just got to go around and
around and around and around right but
what they don't think about is that you
could have a
wheel that's this big and if you just do
one revolution you get more than this
one does in
10 and so we want to just think what is
that one big wheel that if I just roll
it once it makes all of the wheel spins
that I have on this tiny wheel
irrelevant so let's imagine you have
your to-do list right you've got your
one you've got your two you've got your
three that's a three there you go you
got your four you got your five the
thing is is that most of the times these
are B and C Level problems because you
know how to solve them yay but this one
is the A+ problem that you have no idea
how to solve and so we spend all day
every day just crossing these things off
and then we are happy at the end of the
day but then we're sad at the end of the
month because we still haven't solved
the one big problem and so you have to
be comfortable with the idea that you
might not solve it for one day or two
days or 3 days or four days but if you
do solve it on the fifth day you get the
A+ solution that gives
you it takes your wheel from a wheel
that's this big to a wheel that's this
big and from that point going forward
when you're rolling you're getting that
much more for every Revolution and so I
want to make this super Tactical for you
once you've identified what the priority
is what the one thing that matters most
is then typically humans us and your
team will likely not want to do it it's
very much in our human nature to just
continue to work less and less because
it's easier and so these are some
tactics that I have done to pull the
future forward so number one if you
change the meetings from end of week to
end of day or twice a day you will
communicate how much more important it
is you to get those things done so so if
you have a weekly Cadence for something
that is the priority for the business
then you should be meeting far more than
once a week probably more than once a
day number two once you've determined
that that is the priority and you have a
Cadence and deadline Associated that
because you're getting feedback loops
that are installed much faster then you
want to eliminate everything that's not
that now they might sound obvious in
retrospect but it it isn't in reality
especially if you have a team and so the
way that we eliminate is by saying
everything that you are currently
working on is not as important as this
thing which means you need to let some
of these fires burn once you have set
that deadline and you've eliminated
everything else then we increase the
frequency of communication so obviously
the meetings set little mini deadlines
because you want to get things done by
then but in between communication also
needs to ramp up so if you check in on
someone after an hour after meeting and
say hey where are you at that that
communicates a very different idea of
the urgency around the priority or the
problem that you're trying to solve now
once you have that communication Loop in
there what you want to also do or that I
have found effective is to make winning
obvious Clear and Present publicly so
that means that if you have a dashboard
if you have a progress marker a
thermometer something to show anytime
someone sees it the progress that is
being made it acts as a reinforcement
Loop for the entire team to get things
done and if you want to go real advanced
mode put a pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow saying once we fix the
conversion rate on our page then we will
all get this thing together and it could
be we all go out to dinner it could be
hey everybody gets the rest of the day
off whatever day we finish it like you
can make the pot of gold whatever you
want but it also shows what's in it for
them so it's easier to say committed
than to stay committed which is the only
thing that matters now as the boss for
first in the beginning you're boss of
you but over time if you develop a team
you become boss of other people and so
what I have found is that you can't just
increase the priority you need to also
increase the commitment and so
commitment I Define it as the
elimination of Alternatives and so let
me give you a simple example marriage
the ultimate commitment relationship
wise means that you eliminate every
other person from your life literally
who's not your wife or your husband that
you will ever date again so you say you
were the only person I eliminate all
others and that is a commitment if
you're in health if you want to commit
fully to something then it means you
have to eliminate everything else that
is not that thing so that's where you
throw away all the food in your kitchen
that's not aligned with your goal you
pour out all the alcohol you eliminate
the alternative so that the only thing
left is to do the thing that you
committed to and within the context of
business you have to eliminate
everything that is not the priority and
the thing is is that it's very easy to
say you're committed and I've noticed
with my teammates a lot of them are like
I'm committed but it's very hard to show
that you're committed so if you want to
teach this process to your team this is
how I think about it number one is you
prioritize you say there's lots of
things we could do but if we just did
this one thing this would be the most
important the second thing that I do is
I create urgency so I say this is very
important this is when we're going to be
meeting about it we have to get it done
by this time but you can't do that
without all also
eliminating everything else that they
have on their plates it's not fair to
say hey we're now just going to make
this incredibly important thing that's
due tomorrow but you also still have to
do your normal work it doesn't work
they're just like it's not going to work
especially on a continuous basis and if
you do one two and three then what's
going to happen is that you will solve
it and you will solve it significantly
faster than you thought because everyone
will be focused on solving it and
everyone will get out of the way to make
sure that it gets done and then you look
at your list and you
reassess and then you rep prioritize you
set the new urgency you eliminate
everything else and you keep going and
the difference between a bad strategist
and a good strategist just comes down to
the thing that they choose to believe is
the most important so this is how I
applied this four-step process to the
paid ads team that I was talking about
earlier so first off I said okay here
are all the things that are wrong with
our marketing and then I said and we're
going to ignore all of them except for
the pixel issue then I said okay we're
going to meet end of day today because
this was first thing in the morning and
people were like well I have a I have a
meeting right now and I was like oh yeah
is it with me they're like oh no and I
they're like well should I I was like
yeah don't be on the meeting and I was
like and if someone gives you a problem
tell them they can talk to
me then I said that also means that
whatever you're regularly doing for the
day it's not that it's now this and then
we went through every single line item
of what had to happen for the pixel to
get fixed and we assigned every single
line item to each person and I said how
long do you think this will take how
long do you think this will take and by
the way I'm asking I'm not asking for
days here I'm asking for minutes and
hours all right and by the time we're
done it's like great so it looks like we
can get all this stuff done in the next
six hours so we're going to meet again
at 4:30 today so that all of you guys
can show off your work and I can tell
you how great of a job you did then at
the end of this I said okay now every
single person tell me back what you're
going to do next now and so here's
what's interesting people came back and
they said something and it wasn't what I
said so I said let me say it again
you're going to do this you're going to
do this and this is going to reroute
here say it back to me and they said it
it's like right write it down and then I
go back to the person ask him again once
everyone gets it right great we're going
to meet in a few hours I'll see you then
at the time of me making this video
right now I'm between the calls all
right which is why I'm so fired up so
once we get on the call once the pixel's
fixed guess we're going to do we're
going to look at the next thing on that
big old list and say all right we had 20
other things we need to do but tomorrow
we're going to work on this one and
we're going to solve that and the thing
is is that so many businesses what they
have and there's this great analogy for
this is that they have this graveyard of
half built Bridges they never get to the
other side of the river because they
never finished the bridge and so the
thing is is that the company is spending
resource ources building all of these
Bridges putting These Bricks here but
they never get one of these dollars
across to the other side into their bank
account and so this is honestly where
most businesses lose all their money is
building these half built Bridges
because no one focuses on completing
their work so we had a portfolio company
that had a show up rate issue and so
they had uh call it a sales event that
they ran regularly in order to turn
prospects into customers and so we
noticed that they were getting a very
low percentage of their prospects to
show up now they were complaining about
lead quality things like that and so we
said okay if we only got the industry
standard Benchmark of leads to show up
to this event we would increase the
revenue of this business by
35% and given the margin of this
business let's say is 10% we would more
than triple the profit of this business
is there anything else we could do with
the resources we have that would give
that kind of a return a tripling of
profit for no
risk in the next 30 days and since the
answer was no then we said great
everyone in this company the only
priority that you have is to get this
number to go up and so then we did a
number of things to make that one
percentage go up and as a result of that
Focus the business did grow by more than
35% because every single person in the
company was aligned with it and guess
what also happened other things fell by
the wayside other things that were not
as important started to burn we had
little customer service issues we had
little issues in the sales department
these were all little things that
normally would have taken away from the
team's focus on that one thing but
because prioritization is so powerful if
you get the one thing right it makes the
rest of it irrelevant the thing about
doing easy problems is that they're so
tempting because we all want to have
that quick win we want to have one or
two wins hey I want to get my momentum
going but what ends up happening is that
you you eat half your day and then you
get a couple calls a couple
interruptions and then the day is gone
and then the next day you still have
that number one that's sitting at the
top but you filled up with two or three
more easy wins and you never get the big
wins to happen that continuous parade of
little wins never moves the ball forward
you never get the breakthroughs you
never get the growth a big part of why
those A+ problems are the big hairy
problems is because they are soaked in
the unknown we don't know how to solve
them and so I want to give you this
Frame of understanding that I have which
is when you have these other things
underneath two through five on that list
you typically know what you need to
start doing how it's going to go and
what it's going to look like at the end
the number one problem you typically
don't know where to start and you don't
know what to do and you don't know how
it's going to end but you know that if
big picture if you solve that one thing
everything else would be irrelevant and
so part of beginning to solve that
problem is learning to understand the
problem itself and so you can't feel
like you're not making progress when
you're trying to understand it and wrap
your arms around it and so there's an
old saying with how do you eat an
elephant you eat it one bite at a time
and so you just have to start pulling
the thread which is how that's my term
it's like I just start pulling the
thread and see what comes and then as I
pull the red my next pool becomes more
and more obvious to me but you don't
know what the next pool is you don't
know what the next step looks like until
you take the first step and the reason
we don't is because it's unknown long
term you want to make sure the team
understands what the priority is and
that's what you're doing as the boss but
if you want to have faster communication
cycles and more people immediately
aligned with the priority of the
business then what you and this is
something that LE I've worked a lot on
is increasing information transparency
across the company that's a lot of big
words but basically just means that you
want everyone to know the same stuff
because if everyone knows the same stuff
the financials the conversion rates how
we make money the profit margins then
everyone else has the same information
now that might freak you out as an
entrepreneur but I remember when I was
listening to Sam Walton's autobiography
he talked about one of the big fears
that he had was like showing all the
financials but guess what the biggest
companies in the world are publicly
traded and every single employee can see
every single thing you could possibly
imagine about the company and yet they
still function and so it is 100% a an
irrational fear that entrepreneurs keep
by thinking that no one should know and
so I have over time continued to loosen
up my my my you know White Knuckle grip
on information because the more people
who know everything the more people can
help me solve the problems if you were
to come tomorrow and say guys this is
the priority like we're got to do this a
lot of people will get overwhelmed
because they don't know because you also
told them something last week and the
week before was also a priority and
they're not done doing that yet and so
one of the practices that I'd like to do
is to pull up their agenda and say show
me everything you're working on right
now okay because you'll find out that
some things you ask them for two months
ago that they might still be working on
and even if they're not working on it's
taking their attention because they know
they're not working on they think they
should be working on it you're like oh I
totally forgot I even asked you to do
that oh uh we solved that other problem
already in that other department which
makes this problem now relevant so sorry
about that if you have more frequent
Loops where you can look at that list
and say oh no this is more important
than this don't worry about that don't
worry about that this one we can deal
with next week table it this is what I
want you to work on and this is how i'
start you can give someone so much less
anxiety around the work so much Clear
Direction and it gives you the
opportunity to give out adab boys the
moment they do it and if this is going
to help you make more money in your
business here's two more videos like
this that'll help you make even more